42 Thursday morning happening now in Las
Vegas full-scale talent in a very small
style proof Vigor isn't always better
we've got Lauren negretta joining us
line from the Gold Coast this morning
for this um Minicon so just the little
intricacies of some of the things that
you showed us and and you've got a hat
now that is so cool yeah
tip of my hat to you guys good morning
but yeah there is so much to see here
again industry only event that happened
in the first two days but come Saturday
Sunday you can come and buy some of the
things you see here I am with kind of
the apparently the weird Table Right
Here I Am joined by Sandy Leal she's who
you see all these intricate characters
here so Sandy tell me how how you really
find the inspiration for this you know I
just I love to sculpt heads and I I
start out without a plan or if I have
one I seldom reach it
um and I let it the clay tell me what
I'm going to do and what's your favorite
thing you would you would say to that
you like to make here heads absolutely
heads and then I'm put the Armature on
them and my business partner does
costuming because that's my least
favorite
and you were saying that um come that
Saturday Sunday you've actually got some
sales here for people to enjoy if they
speak to them absolutely I've got this
entire table is uh 40 off of the price
and if you buy three or more it's 50
percent
um
yeah and people can actually join
there's a membership club happening
absolutely we meet every uh once a month
the third Saturday at a church and we
are looking for members love that if you
are so inclined to become a miniature
artist yourself here for the hashtag
mini con we got going on you can learn
about that membership table uh as we
come the event again Saturday Sunday
open to the public 12 entry for adults
six dollars for kids eight and over it's
going to be a great event I'm already
having a good time live in Las Vegas
Lauren negretti 8 news now wow she said
heads yes
not messing with those costumes she's
sticking strictly with sculpting great
look at that thanks Lauren appreciate it
thank you thank you Lauren have fun